we're like oh my gosh i'm going to get
out of this yeah
not really uh six marriott sixth and
cost me at nine the answer is given to
you very clearly
buy out rejecting the prophet peace be
upon him no rejecting this hadith
no by accepting all of that and applying
it in the correct way oh guys yeah so
next time
anybody atheists crush whoever they me
maybe
come and ask you the question go and fix
your home first
yeah you've got people white middle-aged
men traveling to
africa yeah africa thailand
these countries to rape boys answer your
question let me do it with that for you
guys
oh yes
assalamu alaikum where i'm gonna tell
you better two brothers and sisters and
dear friends hope you guys are well
inshallah welcome back to this video
this is a video that i've been wanting
to do for a long time but i
never got the chance to and this is a
topic which we have discussed
in many platforms in many venues even in
speaker's corner and i've got many
videos
which highlight this very question being
answered in a different way
but there's another question that these
individuals are asking are these
individuals asking this
uh because they're curious no they're
only just using this as an opportunity
to attack islam because islam is
spreading wide
and all around the world and people are
coming to islam in the thousands and
millions around the world
so they think that this is an argument
to use that islam is false aryan
at six yeah and consummating at nine
this doesn't make the message
untrue it's not like the trinity where
it doesn't make sense at all
it's not like the trinity where the the
father is not the son the son is not the
holy spirit the holy spirit is not the
son
but they're all one and their god and
divine which many people leave
christianity because of
and many apologetics in christian
apologetics
have actually stopped talking about the
trinity they've just dedicated time to
attacking islam and it just shows you
their weakness
and even when it comes from atheists
when it comes to atheists you really
need to question their moral compass you
know because they don't have one
you know it's all based on subjectivity
um and they're here to come and question
us about morality when you have no moral
compass your moral comes
all over the place yeah soon you become
an intelligent having incest
having intimacy with your own brother
sister mom or dad
which many people have said uh certain
atheists like apus
um who's um admitted that if he was
harmless he would have intimacy with his
own
son so as you can see guys these people
have no moral compasses
and they come and mock islam in the
quran and say oh thank god allah told us
that we're not allowed to you're not
allowed to marry your
mom and your uh um and your sisters and
your brother
and your um sons etc what would we do
without the quran so they're mocking the
quran
and the life is on them because that's
actually what's happening you know
you're literally
advocating that and the quran has come
to once again tell you
to get back to your senses and stop
doing that so yeah that's the reason why
i want to do this video
now the question is the following does
islam allow child marriages
now the argument that is used problem
sisters is very simple
if your prophet peace be upon him
married aisha at six
and consummated the marriage at nine
what would you this is the question i
asked was would you
allow your six-year-old daughter to get
married and consummate
the marriage at night now they say they
think that
they've got us and we're like oh my gosh
i'm gonna get out of this
yeah not really because the thing is
it's we've got a beautiful answer which
actually shook so many christian
hate-mongering apologetics even david
wood so much to record that he actually
got so irritated
that there's an answer for this because
why because they're just
lying haters which are after just making
money
so here's the answer which is going to
be a big slap across their face we
follow the prophet peace be upon him
and we believe he was the best mankind
uh best human to work
walk this earth and we follow all his
prophetic traditions
to the best of ability does this
contradict
that's the question here does it
contradict that now
in this very argument i want to answer a
few ways because there's a lot of
fallacies that have been made there's a
fallacy of presentism
there's a fallacy of anachronism and
there's
a fallacy to appeal to the novelty
fallacy yeah
these three fallacies in a nutshell is
telling you that how you
are comparing something that happened
1400 years ago today
it's like me saying for example um the
romans
why did the romans travel or the other
bedouins or
whoever it may be travel so far
distances on camels
why don't why didn't you just get a
ferrari
you know it's it's that kind of
fallacious reasoning that we're dealing
with here
to think that the people back then were
stupid dumb
because you have some privileges today
and new
new moral compasses or whatever it may
be which is shifting every second
and now you're judging the past with
them you know
um and that's exactly what's going on
now it's a simple answer
if the prophet peace be upon him married
ayesha is six and consummated the
marriage up to nine
that is a lesson for us muslims what
does that mean
so here it goes if a adult
girl who's 18 years old in this country
because we need to abide by the law of
the land
says that she wants to marry a boy and
that boy is 15 years old even though he
is
built like a tank islamically
what lesson do we learn from that so
when somebody come and ask me that
question would you allow your daughter
to marry at six and consummate the
marriage at night
i say no because your reasoning
is fallacious if the prophet did that
and waited three years
why did he wait three years to marry her
yeah to marry her why did he have to
wait three years
if you make him out to be someone who i
would have been
yeah and this is your perverted thinking
because these people who are thinking
this
and most of them are white middle-aged
man who come and question me about this
and i'm like broth
no offense i'm gonna be racist here but
most pedophiles look like you
yeah this issue of pedophilia is not a
muslim issue you don't see anybody
coming and justifying as a muslim saying
i married
my uh this girl at six no you get people
like
fanatics who isis who would justify
killing innocent people
because and they get certain verses in
the quran but you never see muslims
coming and saying
or that we have an epidemic of muslims
marrying young girls it doesn't exist
but in the western world pedophilia is
on an alarming level even in the church
so this is actually your problem
if the prophet peace be upon him did
that well what that teaches us
is if he waited three years why did he
wait three years
if he had that kind of thinking process
he could just say no
i want her at six why did he have to
wait
till she was nine because she had to
become an adult
right she had to become an adult now
if you're going to do the same thing and
apply these fallacies to yourself
where you're going to say nine six years
old and a nine-year-old and you can look
at
today's standards well that's where the
problem is
we applied the same thing today just as
we said about that girl who wants to
marry that
boy she's 18 he's 15. or he's 18 she's
15
he has to wait for her to reach a legal
age in this country to become an adult
so we do follow the prophet muhammad
peace be upon him and we do apply it
today
because the fact that he waited tells us
that we have to wait for our child
to reach the age of puberty now we have
an evidence this doesn't go far
this argument was never used in history
fifteen hundred years
not a single person who hated the guts
of the prophet muhammad peace be upon
him in islam
not a single one came and said hold on a
second
why did your prophet marry eyeshot six
and cosmetics at night zilch
until 100 years ago where orientalists
brought this thing up and because things
were changing and industrial revolution
was happening
and children were working in factories
were dying and all these kind of other
elements
and this whole concept of teenagers was
brought in
etc etc etc which changed the dynamics
of our thought process
and our moral compass today this is the
reason why people have an issue today
so this is the reason why we say we
apply the same thing today
we have to wait for a person to become
an adult now when we go
when we go to william blackstone right
so basically uh this was about the laws
of england 1893 by syrian william
blackstone chapter 17 of
guardians and ward part two yeah so here
we can read
for ourselves yeah this was in the uk
100 years ago 120 years ago yeah
a female also at seven years of age may
be
betrothed betroth does not mean
consummation just as the prophet married
at the sixth
and waited to consume her nine when she
became an adult
and he says or given in marriage at nine
is intate
entitled to dowry at twelve is at the
years of maturity
so you can see even in surah aside from
a mistake allah says
test the orphan goes until they reach an
age of
marriage to give them their property
yeah so
as you can see guys the question of can
you child marriages allowed in islam
the definition of marriage in islam is
not
like today where people are just having
like you're married you get you just
have intimacy or
to be honest in today's time you have
intimacy uh for years ten years twenties
and then you end up getting married
they've reversed the whole thing yeah
in islam you can have a marital contract
yeah and then once that girl reaches the
age of maturity yes
1400 years ago yeah this was happening
120 years ago
in the uk yeah so if she reached the age
of puberty if eyeshadow and the age of
nine said i do not want to marry the
prophet
she could have say no because forced
marriages are haram in islam
so as you can see guys i'll just repeat
again and i'll end of in this note
would i allow my daughter as six to
marry and cause me at nine
no why no because i'm following the
hadith of the prophet peace be upon him
at his time at his time the context
of an adult was when they reached the
age of maturity which for aisha was nine
if her if she was a original maturity at
uh um um 10 11 12 13 or 14
the prophet waited three years he would
have waited that much longer why would
he wait three years
i'm not gonna wait another two years or
three years so you can see clearly that
we are implementing the very hadith that
you're talking and you're asking this
question i want answering very directly
yes we are applying the same standards
today that if my daughter my daughter
was
12 13 years old yes and she said she
wants to get married
i would have to tell her yes you might
be sexually ready
you might be ready physically but you're
not mentally you might not be mentally
ready you're not ready for marriage
yeah and this is where another video out
of mind was cut out of context when i
was discussing with somebody yeah
so even today we have issues of teenage
pregnancies girls having sex
behind the bushes at the age of 11 12 13
14
15 as young as that and this whole issue
in america is one of different states
so this issue of pedophilia is a i'm so
sorry if it's going to be any problem
it's going to be a western problem it's
a muslim problem
so you can see clearly that when we
implement the hadith
that means i would tell my daughter no
you have to wait at least
you're 16 17 yeah why because the legal
age of this country yeah which is 16
but where p uh france just reduced it to
15
so they're pedophiles according to our
eyes and we are pedophile
promoting country according to a lot of
muslim countries which the age limit is
18 to get married so you can see the
double standards here yeah
so as i said we find our end on this
that is how we implement that and that
is the reason why child marriages are
not
allowed in islam it's as simple as that
you cannot cause harm
yes it mentions very clear that you
cannot cause harm to somebody
so you can't cause harm to someone just
because they've developed certain body
parts you know
especially in today's age you know
you'll have your 11 12 acorn
he he was done for you know having
intimacy with
a um a a girl who's under the age of 16
but he was seeing
rob he even made a track called put the
blame on me you know
why because he was like what's she doing
in a club that's 18 plus and what the
girl was at 13 or 12 or something like
this
and she was like a full-grown woman
you're a full-grown woman so just
because she has those certain body fats
it doesn't mean she is ready for
intimacy sexually
or physically this is what islam came to
protect the rights of
when the girls were seen as nothing but
property let alone they've been buried
alive so much so like intellectuals like
jordan peterson when it comes to the
issue of isis marriage the prophet peace
be upon him he doesn't criticize
because it's an intellectual he realizes
the paradigm shift in those times 1400
years ago
to today and the same thing can be
applied today like i explained
the very question of can is child
marriages allowed in islam when i let my
daughter marry at six
and uh uh six marry at six and cut me at
nine the answer is given to you very
clearly
buy out rejecting the prophet peace be
upon him no rejecting this hadith
no by accepting all of that and applying
it in the correct way
and even when you see in this video when
i speak to this young boy
this young man you can see that he came
with a genuine
uh question he wanted to know why did
why did this happen
and when we explained to him and he
listened to learn not listen to reply
you saw that he left saying you know
what i understand
it made sense but when somebody's filled
with um
anger yeah with hatred with lies about
islam and that's what he wants to do
just to make some money
in his pocket they don't give them an
explanation they will not
accept it and as you can see today with
atheism and
secularism and this this moral compass
that is all over the place
that if certain people in history looked
at us they'll say these guys are out of
their mind they're animals
you know think about this what they
would say you know they would say you
know all this said homosexuality was a
mental disorder
how many years ago now it's okay they're
working their way to incest
incest yes even pedophiles are looking
for their own rights i was born like
this
just as homosexual says i was born off
gay well the pedophile saying no
i was born like this you know and he
wants to join the lgbqt community but
they're rejecting them
no so do you see the double standards
and the moral compass that is
all over the place so guys yeah so next
time anybody
atheists crush whoever they me maybe
come and ask you the question and try to
not ask this question criticize and
insult
go and fix your home first yeah you've
got people white middle-aged men
traveling to africa yeah africa
thailand these countries to rape boys
right rape little boys yeah your your
own backyard is a disgusting dirty mess
yeah dirty mess and don't let's get
started with the church
yeah the pastors at church don't let us
don't get started with dead bodies found
of children who are raped yeah let's not
get started here this is your problem
don't throw dirt on us so until next
time guys alhamdulillah
we are proud to defend the honor of the
prophet salallahu and we'll do it till
the day we die inshallah may allah
accept it from us hope this is answered
your question let me do it with that for
you guys
oh yes and guys
goodbye too